so i've got a question from kaspars and
the question is uh when talking about
pre-sleep protein which we've mentioned
on the show several times before
uh the question is are we talking about
20 or 30 minutes before bed with a
protein ingestion or are we talking
about two or three hours before bed
and what they're getting at is they're
based on the question they're a little
concerned about this idea of
pre-bed food intake interfering with
sleep quality um you know because our
stomach can get upset
body temperature can be elevated due to
digestion which can be uh unfavorable
for sleep you know
you want to kind of get your core
temperature down a little bit for for
sleep
um so is it really worth sacrificing
sleep quality in order to promote muscle
protein synthesis so as i've mentioned
on previous episodes i think we've
talked about it on the show i'm not
convinced that the pre-bed feeding
opportunity is a unique opportunity i
think as long as you're getting
ideally somewhere between three to six
servings of protein throughout the day i
don't think it's critical to have one of
those be 20 minutes before bed or two
hours before bed i just simply don't
think it matters based on the evidence
available
um now the question about that trade-off
of let's say it's late at night and
you're like i've only gotten a couple
protein feedings and should i go for it
or should i be worried about interfering
with sleep um you know the question was
what do the studies actually do if
you're looking at the studies that look
at nighttime proteins specifically
impacting body composition
those do provide protein
relatively close to bedtime so the most
common approach that you'll see in that
small collection of studies is going to
be a protein shake so it'll be a liquid
form of protein given somewhere between
30 to 90 minutes before bed somewhere in
that time frame
the problem is with those studies
because they're so focused on body
composition they really don't say much
about how it impacted sleep quality it's
kind of up in the air there are a couple
studies i've reviewed over the past
couple years in mass that have looked at
pre-bed protein um you know different
types of protein with different amounts
of tryptophan and how those might
influence sleep
because tryptophan is a precursor to
serotonin and melatonin
and so having elevated tryptophan in the
brain at night could theoretically
promote you know a quicker onset of
sleep
in addition to better sleep quality so
for those studies where they actually
looked at sleep quality
they uh they did have it kind of further
away from bedtime we're talking about
like two or three hours before bed so
while those studies give us an
opportunity to look at how this protein
is impacting sleep quality unfortunately
it's pretty far removed from sleep time
like i said a couple hours at minimum
and so it doesn't really get to the root
of this question which is like
should i chug a protein shake right
before bed or is that going to mess up
my sleep so um the research available
unfortunately it kind of takes
one of two approaches so far which is
either put it close to bed and don't
measure sleep quality or put it further
from bed and do measure sleep quality
and i don't think that's intentional i
think that's just the way it goes when
you're looking at a body of literature
that is very small and they haven't
really had an opportunity to test
through all different permutations of
timing and outcome measurements so
i for now would recommend just using a
little bit of trial and error i think a
lot of times uh sleep disruption related
to pre-bed meal intake can be really
complicated so you want to go to bed you
certainly don't want to be too hungry
because that can interfere with sleep
for sure just ask any bodybuilder that
that becomes one of the hardest things
in prep in my opinion is trying to sleep
when hungry um but you also don't want
to be too full
that can be uncomfortable and like the
uh the question suggests you know you
can have that discomfort of digestion
elevated body temperature things like
that so you want to be not too hungry
not too full
but you also have to consider what does
this meal look like so some of these
studies they'll just give a liquid
protein shake you know very very easy to
digest
and that's quite different from a very
unprocessed meal with a bunch of fat in
it a bunch of fiber intake so the the
things that often disrupt sleep when
consumed before bed usually a fatty meal
especially if it tends to be pretty
spicy that is not a good combination for
a pre-bed meal that would support really
good sleep
but i think a lot of this is very
susceptible to variation between
individuals i think you probably want to
do some trial and error see if a
particular pre-bed meal disrupts your
sleep if it does you might
go for something that's more digestible
you know you might change up your food
sources or you might change the timing
and like i've said previously if you
decide to just move that pre-bed meal to
way earlier and kind of
miss out on that feeding opportunity
immediately before sleep i really don't
think you're you're sacrificing much in
the process